Not only was I receiving hatred from the
right in my country but I was receiving
Awards and praise from the left so I was
getting like more and more radicalized
and feeling like if I didn't
please everyone and piss off the right
people then I was a bad person and and
art making you know under that amount of
scrutiny I wasn't really able I didn't
feel like I could play
[Music]
anymore Emma alitz welcome to H the
light gets in thank
you so your Public Image has largely
been shaped by your sexual assault
Survivor story and uh the performance
art pieces that came in response to that
what were you trying to achieve with uh
that bit of performance art and why did
you choose that Medium to tell your
story um wow okay this is a throwback
question
um after the assault
um I didn't tell anyone uh I except for
you know my closest friends they
gossiped word spread and then uh I was
at a party
and a girl came up to me and she was
like I heard about what
happened
um the guy who did that to you did the
same thing to me and then she'd also
heard some rumors about other women and
we went on this kind of like detective
Journey where we contacted the other
women and found out that there were
actually six of us who'd all been
assaulted by the same guy so we reported
our cases to the school and the police
and they did
nothing um
so really I was in a position
where nothing was going to be done like
my fate had already been decided and
um I
had always been interested in art I
really believed that art good art was
supposed to effectively communicate uh
you know your emotional state some
experience you've had and so I just
wanted to make art about what had
happened I mean there was really I think
a lot of people when they asked that
question when they asked me uh what were
you trying to accomplish or what you
know what were were your motivations I
think there's this assumption that there
were some sort of you know ulterior
motives but really I I just was trying
to make an artwork about it's like if
someone were really
hurt um and they wanted to make a song
about their breakup you don't ask them
like so were you trying to get back
together with him by right like no it's
just this is how I felt and I thought
that art is supposed to communicate how
you feel uh so I thought that um I was
at this artist residency it was a very
prestigious artist residency out in the
middle of nowhere Connecticut and I had
never made artwork before that wasn't
assigned to me by my
teachers uh so I made this very boring
and bad video where I was filming myself
dancing in a room and uh I was like okay
how do I make this better cuz it sucks
so I asked one of my friends at the
residency to film me setting up for this
video and taking everything apart at the
end um and when I reviewed that footage
I was really interested in this one
moment it just was curious to me where I
was clearing the furniture out the
furniture out of the room to film in
there and I uh was moving the bed out
and I was like oo that's interesting to
just like watch my body at these angles
dealing with this mattress I don't know
why I really didn't know why but I was
like I want to explore that further and
I asked her to film me carrying it
carrying the mattress further out out of
the house and onto the front lawn and it
was even more interesting to watch out
was like wow there's such a struggle to
bring this bulky object out of the
bedroom and into the light and I was
just fascinated by it again no like how
do I create an artwork that will Comm
like you know I was just like that's
interesting let me follow that um and
then I thought like what what what why
is this interesting to me oh maybe
because the mattress represents the
weight of what I endured maybe it
represents the weight of you know all
survivors must endure and then I was
like well to make it even clearer to
make it an even better artwork I should
do it at Columbia right so this is kind
of how it came about there was never a
moment where I was like Sor it's a long
answer but it's complicated no it's
great do you think that a lot of uh a
lot of artists like that that the sort
of It kind of people produce these
things and then the stories about them
are kind of retrospective we understand
art after it's been produced rather than
start out with a plan of what this piece
is going to be about and what it's going
to mean and then carry it out
I think I think nowadays um I mean I I
I've taught at The Graduate level you
know for art and I've been in so many
art classes and been around a ton of
artists who are in art school and
whatever and I think so many people are
taught you know okay come up with what
your artwork is about and then figure
out how to make it so people will be
like okay I'm going to make an artwork
about loneliness and modern-day society
and then they end up with like a stick
leaning against the wall and then that's
why you go to an art a College art
exhibition and you see like 50 sticks
leaning against the wall right but when
I teach or when I work with artists I
really try and push them to just follow
the weird intuition you have don't don't
come in with preconceived notions about
the art you want to make just like you
know oh you happen to be really
interested in collecting socks I know
that's not artwork for you but can you
follow that weird thing you're
interested in and see where it takes you
and consider why you're interested in
that I try to have people do it I mean
that's my method to follow the kind of
like inexplicable impulse and then
retrospectively see why you were
interested in that in the first place so
I I P I push
that and what about sort of the issue of
sort of social change especially with
our pieces that are explicitly touching
upon something that is um a political
issue or a social issue of the time you
know is it reasonable to expect Art to
change the world or is that a naive no
it's ridiculous and I can't believe
anyone has ever thought such a
thing I
uh I mean I really did not set out to
change the world when I did mattress
performance I I didn't think anyone was
going to give a [__] about my stupid
artwork
um but I think it's what it speaks to is
that if you
can create an artwork that succinctly
expresses something you're feeling in a
way that is clear and um
communicable then it will speak to
people because you know we're all humans
and we've all suffered something in our
lives so I think that's when artwork can
touch people and move them and I
mean I think that's when artwork starts
to
become more powerful than you could have
ever
thought and do you think that's the
reason why kind of explicitly political
art or art that sets out to be political
often kind of leaves us quite cold
because it has that sort of instrumental
element from the start I yeah I think
that's the word it's
in it becomes Like Instrumental yes
propagandistic even like I'm so
interested in people just following
their weird instincts you know um
whatever makes them tick because
ultimately I think if you follow that to
its logical conclusion there's something
that's about that that is going to
resonate with people and it's going to
inevitably become quite political but um
yeah I I don't I
mean there's value in in art that's very
instrumental in that way but I'm not I'm
not uh I'm not someone who works in that
in that
way okay let's talk about I talk about
something I heard you say earlier uh in
the debate on this kind of issue of
change and control and the fact that
when you made that artwork you felt like
well the institutions aren't going to
change or at least they're not going to
change anything when it comes to this
particular case yeah so so it was a kind
of way of changing something you could
change which is you your yourself or
yeah so is it a way of asserting control
is creativity a way of kind of impacting
the
world in in maybe smaller ways than you
know we originally maybe imagin we
should be changing the world yeah yeah I
was saying saying that you know we
really
only have control over ourselves and our
reactions to things um you know if I set
out to try and fix this person change
that institution and um help these 10
people I'm going to
fail in all in every
way um I think that
uh
that I'm much more interested in um
doing the work I need to do on myself um
and hoping that that in and of itself is
inspiring to others um and uh I think
that inspiring others is much more
powerful than trying to change control
or fix
others how do you how do you escape s a
very personal art like yours from
becoming a bit solipsistic right being
too self-referential too much about you
know
your own experiences or your own
references that maybe are going to be a
bit opaque to the rest of the world I
know this is something often told to
young poets when they start out you
know yeah exactly so how because there's
this kind of interesting contradiction
in your work which is both kind of
intensely polit sort of personal but
also has this kind of like
wider um sort of impact and and and and
resonates with people so how how does
art balance the two they kind of very
paral the universal um I make no claims
to not be a total
narcissist but I think that
actually okay I'm going to say something
I hope is not you know whatever maybe
it's it's controversial and maybe all
three of you will hate me for saying
this we like controversy all right great
so you know when have you ever met those
people who say oh I'm an empath and I'm
surrounded by narciss ists in my life
and they're all vampires sucking my
energy and woe is me I'm an
empath um I worry that only narcissists
talk that
way like like uhoh this is starting to
sound like actually you're the
narcissist maybe so um to avoid that I
just act like a narcissist all the time
because I feel like it's the to make fun
of the whole situation is the only way
to actually not be narcissistic so I
mean I'll often like toot my own horn or
like act act like I'm the center of the
world but I I only make those jokes
because I know that I'm definitely not
you know what I mean um so I guess
like uh I recognize that contradiction
and I think it's kind of unavoidable so
you have to lean into it you've got to
lean into it and make it funny at the
very least I think play is the only way
around these things when it comes to
again the sort of like art that has a
kind of moral content or political
content what role in how we evaluate art
does the kind of moral or political
content of it play like can we
separate the message of a piece of art
from it's like aesthetic or other
qualities or do the two kind of always
go together you know I think I'm just at
a point now I'm old I'm 29 I I'm just
not interested in valuing art or like
putting a valuation on Art like I I
think you know if you see something and
you like it then I'm happy you found it
like I'm happy your day just got better
you know I'm not here to say I'm not
interested in in going around being like
well this is a good artwork and that's a
bad artwork like and and also I think
that you know as much as I say like you
know before we were talking about which
what my artistic process is versus what
you know an artistic process that does
not resonate with me but
um I really believe it's important for
people to make bad art because if you
don't make bad art you're never going to
make good art you know and and oh my God
how I've made some bad art you know but
if I never did that I would have never
learned all learned from all those
mistakes like okay well that didn't
speak to anyone which is why it's
sitting in a closet somewhere let me try
let me try something different next what
makes what makes a piece of art bad
other than the fact that people don't
like it or um or is that the measure of
the success of a art piece I guess I'm
what I'm saying is
uh I wish everyone would just chill out
and make whatever the [__] they want to
make you and stop trying so hard
to to be the best all the time like I
I'm such a fan of mediocre art I think
it's so like I'm so happy that people
are taking risks making
mistakes
um yeah go bad
art this a kind of like it kind of you
know you need to fail and fail again and
fail in better ways or yeah and I wish
people wouldn't be punished for for
making [__] you know um so what's your
what's your relationship to Art now
you've mentioned in an interview
previously that you were leaving the art
world are you are you have you have you
left that is that behind you are you
back in into it what's what's the
current situation I mean I haven't
really felt the need to make artwork
since I I mean um you know after making
mattress performance and uh becoming
kind of the figurehead of
this budding political movement um I I
lost a lot of freedom you know I Not
only was I receiving hatred from the
right in my country but I was receiving
Awards and prais from the left so I was
getting like more and more radicalized
and feeling like if I didn't
please everyone and piss off the right
people then I was a bad person and and
art making you know under that amount of
scrutiny I wasn't really able I didn't
feel like I could play anymore I it felt
like
drudgery and you know I'd always loved
art because it was this space of freedom
for me and this place where I could be
weird and creative and um once I lost
that I was like I don't really you know
I'm not interested in it anymore so
lately um I've been um getting a
master's of Science in uh Chinese
medicine um and learning how to give
treatments to patients and I've actually
found a new space for creativity um
one day I had this one patient and I was
like I'm just bored of giving the same
boring ass treatments over and over
again I I need to have some fun and um I
remember sitting there I have these two
assistants and I was like okay I'm going
to do like five acupuncture points but
we need to do something kind of weird
and cutesy um so I took a cue from
another teacher IID had and I was like
I'm we're going to do like an energy
thing so you put one hand your you know
your hand on his hand like this and then
you the other assistant put your hand
like this and then you're both going to
Cross Your Hands over his heart and I'm
going to mess up the microphone and and
we're going to like send him good energy
but I need you guys to like prepare for
this so they were like okay yeah yeah
yeah so they were like meditating and
getting their Chi ready their know the
Chinese word for energy and then we did
this like very performance
artes energy transfer for him and the
treatment was just so much more powerful
and I note was kind of [__] but just
having everyone engage in this
performance art piece for you know to me
it's a performance art piece to them it
was a you know an energy transfer or
whatever it
just it was like exciting and thrilling
and like I realized that actually
there's a ton of room for creativity and
the next treatment I gave I was like you
know what I'm going to come up with
another kind of like mini Performance
Based on this person's story and their
trauma for this person what what how do
you think of the relationship as aware
between art and and healing are the two
connected in any other in any way Beyond
kind of the way that you've explored in
in alternative kind of uh Medical
Treatments like if we look at Art in
itself does that does that have a kind
of healing capacity um yeah um there's
this essay by Georgio gambin that I read
in college and then I couldn't find it
for many years and then I finally found
it again like a few weeks ago but I
haven't had a chance to reread it so I'm
probably not going I'm probably going to
Mis recount it uh but in it he talks
about the role of the Contemporary as
someone who kind of stands outside of
society and is able to perceive all of
it and from that kind of position
they're able to actually um
distill it into something that's
meaningful for society so the artist is
able to for example be so receptive to
everything that's happening in society
that they can distill it into something
um like simple and meaningful to
everyone um that's you know
his you know that's aspirational you
know that's what that's what we should
aspire to
be and um I've I've always tried to do
that like in my art like how can I not
impose my views on the situation but be
so receptive to everything that I'm
perceiving that it you know magically
distills into an artwork and I feel like
in in my healing practice I'm doing the
same with my patients like someone sits
in front of me and I'm listening to
their story I'm also looking at the
lines on their face I'm seeing the way
they hold their arms I'm seeing the way
they breathe um I'm listening to the
sound of their voice and all of this
information is informing me on how I'm
going to proceed with the treatment in
the way I speak in the way I walk around
the room you know all sorts of things so
it's so art and healing they're really
to me it's really
similar going back to something you
mentioned earlier about how kind of the
celebrity stasis that you
acquired sort of uh was a hindrance to
your Crea ity do you think that's true
of of all kind of celebrity culture when
it comes to Art is that have we reached
a point when there's so much exposure
and people become so scrutinized through
I don't know social media and people
following them all the time yeah that it
actually is detrimental to to
creativity um you know I think it can be
looking back I I think had I been older
and wiser um maybe I would have found a
way to carve carve that space out for
myself um but I think I was so young and
impressionable that I felt like I had to
be on all the time and taking every
interview and giving every speech and
all this stuff um I mean the last time
I I spoke publicly I think was like at
this Festival like maybe 3 or 4 years
ago so I think I reached a point where
was like okay you know what I'm able
to create these boundaries for myself
take a step back and build some privacy
for myself um like I think I'm coming
back out into the public eye
because I'm pretty excited about what
I've learned during that period of time
that I went into a cave and
hid um and so I wouldn't make a blanket
statement about you know what publicity
does does to everyone rather I
would think about the ways in which it's
really important when you are in that
position of publicity to intentionally
carve out some privacy for yourself and
remember to like do self-care blah blah
blah and what have you learned in your
four years in your in your dark cave in
my convalescence I think I
I went on a crazy adventure where I
spoke with people who really hated me um
but I was ready at that point to
approach them with a smile and you know
a genuine desire to get along um and I
learned that change doesn't happen
overnight um there's no use in being
upset with people if they
don't understand you the first time
around um which taught me patience which
taught me patience
so uh
uh I was able you know once you learn
that you can talk with people who you
really disagree with and be patient as
they open up you know without trying to
force the matter another way of saying
it is in Chinese philosophy one of the
fundamental concepts is
that uh change is the only constant in
this universe so in Western philosophy
um it's very our our grip on reality is
very rigid right like if um this arm of
the chair is a rectangular shape it
means it's not a circle it's not round
um but in Chinese philosophy the fact
that it's a rectangular shape means that
it has the potential to become a circle
someday everything has the potential to
change and I think that um often in
politics we don't remember that we lose
sight of that we we treat people as if
like okay you're wrong so you suck suck
it's like okay well in the Eastern
philosophy maybe they're wrong today
they could be right tomorrow they you
know or maybe it'll take them 10 years
to figure it out but um there's no use
in getting so upset when people when
people take a bit of time you know emitz
thank you for taking your time thank
[Music]
you